hey everyone thanks for joining welcome
to today's presentation we're going to
talk about building a hybrid data
pipeline with Kafka and confluent my
name is Josh Michael I lead partner
solutions engineering at confluent I'm
excited today to be joined by sarthak
from GCP both are thick and GCP are have
been great partners to us over the years
so start thick please introduce yourself
and take it away
awesome thanks Josh and thanks everyone
for joining as Josh mentioned my name is
Arthur I'm a partner engineer for Google
but GCD for North America and I worked
but it closely with Josh on designing
this architectures and solving discussed
robotics so first let me spend a few
minutes understanding the agenda so we
are going to first talk about what's the
exact problem statement which we are
trying to solve today what is a budget
offer and what is constant we are hoping
everyone in this audience is familiar
with capita but this is just for today
we are going to talk about how to great
hydrojet of pipelines using kaufman
compliment and finally we are going to
look at some of the common use cases
from a design patterns which our
customers have implemented in production
and having great success going to this
idea about that one business problem
which you also seen her personal lines
which probably all of you can relate to
is the total volume of data which is
getting produced and consumed completely
both on an individual level as well as
an enterprise level is increasing
thankful and and also the window of
opportunity when you can actually take
the data and take business insights
helpful visuals and size is reducing
trusted one example of that is happening
all around us with covalent coronavirus
and and all the aftermath of that from
economic political business competitive
landscape which is changing every day
every week now with a tremendous
increase in a volume of data from
business standpoint if you have to make
a decision on how to best adjust your
business both at a at a larger
organization level as well as a lot of
smaller are tactical
project clear the land every delicious
lemon your window opportunities really
low it's strong a few hours a few days
when you have to actually process the
data and understand how best to take
actions based on data if you look at
over the last decade or so how this
industry has kind of a bond it is
primarily on batch deduct where a large
volume of data gets is collected over
the day only a small amount of data is
gets used during the day other data is
kind of uploaded for FTP or other
technologies for nightly job or weekly
job and then it is kind of process of
life oftentimes what happens is because
of because of the batch nature of that
cleaner the business decisions what he
will take kind of lags by a huge module
we have seen for example the fraud
detection risk scenarios we have seen
many times it takes it takes weeks even
months for them to determine whether
reporting the transaction or set of
transactions were a fraud or whether a
set of transactions at pollination to
determine whether it was a fraudulent
transaction a lot in today's world more
and more organizations are trying to
take these decisions in more near
real-time so they are trying to capture
opportunities from things like market
trend analysis or user behavior tracking
again a user were a retail is running on
their website and apps you are doing and
if I do predict their behavior and
provide mode you know provide more
relevant suggestions and recommendations
or so on and so forth with as near
real-time as possible and not based on
what they use our data weak back and too
much time and similarly even in case a
reduction of risk
other than fraud detection from bad
after identification in a whole bunch of
other use cases lot more and more
enterprises needs to make this take
these decisions in near real-time so
with that challenge in mind a lot of
times the customers come to cloud one to
GCP and try to leverage some of the
capabilities and the idea we'll have
abilities Imus our abilities the GC beam
is awesome act and try to see how can we
leverage those Google capabilities to
actually solve those from him secondary
attack and but when they look at their
on-premise system one thing which kind
of stands out in a lot of times is they
might be heavily invested in copper and
hopefully all of you are rating of your
February captor Kafka is is a messaging
platform it is for pub/sub if the pop
server is extremely scalable messaging
platform the whole idea of messaging and
publish/subscribe is is nothing new this
has been there from the from the good ol
days of you know JMS to MP we have seen
many incarnations coming out of link
daily I think in 2011 have you got a few
smart software engineers over in
LinkedIn what Kafka did it kind of
reinvented the whole world of pockets of
time and created the system which is
which is infinitely scalable extremely
fault tolerant which can scale across
multiple servers while the media centers
on evil chakra piece and it had this way
to store all the data infinitely in the
form of logs so you could have created
this brand new architecture and how
pops-up should work and which lend an
excu you been as a volume of data kept
increasing so a lot of enterprises I
have actually standardized over the last
decade or so under Kafka especially
today with backed by the Apache it has
kind of become the backbone or how all
the discrete systems are kind of coming
together in the enterprise data center
so what we thought we'll try to talk
about today is how can you leverage your
existing investment in Kafka and and try
to use that to do this near real-time
you know near real-time use cases on GCV
so this is exactly what hybrids hybrid
streaming is trying to solve that using
GCP + conflict and the consequent cloud
specifically which we have not talked of
a little later how can we actually
get up from there on French systems from
your existing compound without changing
anything on minimally anything and move
the data DCP and start leveraging the
world-class surveillance no logs
extremely scalable an extremely powerful
analytics platform which Google offers
across products like bigquery to data
flow to to looker and everything else so
I'm going to hand it over to Josh who is
going to kind of walk you through about
what is a budget Kafka and what is the
distributed event streaming platform and
and how does the whole thing and a face
set into this vision of so with that or
do you know SH thank sarthak I think
sarthak did a really good job describing
the need for real-time data and it's a
background about Kafka and I think I'm
expecting that many of you have at least
heard or know about Kafka at a high
level I'd like to just take a little bit
of time to talk about some of the key
features about Kafka that we think
really differentiated and make it a
streaming platform rather than just you
know pub/sub messaging so Kafka is most
widely known as kind of the de facto
pub/sub messaging platform it is highly
highly distributed and has a ton of
different use cases throughout
organizations what people don't know is
that or might not know is that Kafka
also stores data so similar to HGF HDFS
Kafka's stores data replicated in a
durable way and you can store as much
debt as you want so you can sort an
infinite amount of data on a Kafka
cluster Kafka also allows you to process
data so via Kafka streams case equal or
even single matches transformations in
the cough Connect framework you can
interact with the data in real time as
it's moving through on that last slide I
mentioned Kafka was an event streaming
platform I think a lot of people aren't
familiar with the term event streaming
or probably think like why did you
create a new term we already have kind
of existing terms for data
infrastructure and we think that kind of
with this new age of data and how
businesses are starting to build their
business around
streaming in real-time that it that it
really it does matter and there is
really this new paradigm shift towards
real-time event streaming and so we
created this this new phrase in in in
this it really has four requirements to
it so there it's built for real-time its
scalable to all types of data its
persistent and durable and it's capable
of enrichment so you can interact with
the data as it's moving through the
system in real time and there are other
existing data infrastructure tools out
there that provide you know a lot of
these but they don't only provide all of
them so you could put together a number
of different systems or you could use
you know Apache Kafka and compliment and
get the best Best of Breed event
streaming platform some of the key
pieces of event streaming and
specifically for this hybrid streaming
data pipelining we're talking about is
being able to connect systems together
and in kafka the way you connect systems
is via aptly named the cockpit Connect
framework so Kafka Connect provides a
framework to easily boot connectors the
ecosystem is built you know over a
hundred different connectors to
different systems so I can pull data
from pretty much anywhere and I can push
data to pretty much anywhere and well
that data is in Kafka I can interact
with it
view something called Kafka streams so
Kafka streams a Java library to do
stream processing within the coffee
ecosystem on top of Kafka streams we've
built case equal case equal is a sequel
syntax that's an abstraction layer on
top of Kafka stream so for non
developers you're able to interact with
these streams of data in real time
so with Kafka connecting Kafka streams
were able to really simplify data
architectures so instead of having um
you know tens or hundreds of systems
that need to talk to tens or hundreds of
systems we can move data through Kafka
we can interact with that data with
Kafka streams we can transform it we
could merge streams and then we can push
those streams to the systems that really
want like bigquery get pulled that pull
the data from data to data flow push it
to GCS
now let's think about this more from a
customer's perspective right so what
would this look like in the real world
so if we look on the left we have a very
simplified view of some data
infrastructure right we have a bunch of
applications they look like
micro-services applications that are
communicating via Kafka an event-driven
way some of those applications are
directly communicating with some data
sources we also have data lakes and
other databases that are connecting to
Kafka pushing and pulling data they may
be creating materialized views in Kafka
for those applications to read and
that's on Prem or hidden it's in some
other cloud right and then we have where
people want to go right like the world's
moving towards the cloud GCP has
world-class analytics so we want to get
we want it as a customer take part in
the streaming analytics so I'm gonna let
start that kind of talk about how we can
connect these these two worlds thanks
Josh
when you talk a lot of time or in
different customers often telling their
journey wants to they want to start with
Google's world of world-class analytics
from their desire might be to start with
TCP to use bigquery because you cannot
process massive amount of data are much
faster because you might want to use big
sheets to connect the data into into
machines and then processing a
business-friendly way or you might do
also visualizations using looker and so
on and so forth now what do you see on
the right-hand side this is a pretty
representative architecture of what the
data pipeline on a DCP might look like
first of the left you have observed
which is Google's own abortion of pops
of a messaging platform
this is server less extremely fault
tolerant extreme which you're
distributed Google medic pop server
which is very heavily used it's at
Google and a lot of customers using and
this is typically what you're starting
quietens so there were jumped arena in
and then the data can get picked up on
another subscription pop surf topic and
then flows through data flow bad there
is a processing store the data in
bigquery which is Google's extremely
scalable no ops
and then finally might do some
visualizations is the data studio on the
card on the other hand you might also
want to take the same data processing
through data flow and then store it you
in in GCS in storage you say you know in
final form is like after or party or
whatnot keep in mind this of any group
does not've architecture there have a
lot of variations from instead of data
and even observable languages yes or
instead of just doing visualizations you
wait on the trigger actions using music
functions based on read and bigquery or
you might want to you know use AI ml you
speak UML for that part of matter the
query ml or the other energy now as as
Josh mentioned that this is always kind
of the desire state right this is the
high level data pipeline which you want
to go towards but your reality is what
you'll eyes on and left and especially
if you have invested in concur so what
we were trying to see is is how can you
actually leverage those existing
infrastructure in pushing the date honey
so the way customers typically do it
today means pub/sub has an SDK parcel
has REST API is using those they can
actually push the data from the
different applications and the Divas
frozen and main tricks and whatnot to
pops up and they have no cups of it can
start all these data contracts though
this works
the challenge with this is depending on
how complex that on prep ecosystem is
you might need to have included SD game
to so many different applications and
deployed in production you know and that
itself can be a daunting and a pretty
complicated project especially if you
have technologies as well as mainframe
as/400 so honest so what we started to
look at is if that enterprise are
already invested in Kafka how can we
actually leverage that to make that
journey a little better manner possible
so confluent cloud which is available as
like a first party service on GC p it is
available directly to marketplace with
direct integration of Billings and
would and integrating with I am
networking all the kind of stuff they
have this awesome capability called
concern indicator so if you're using if
you are using Kafka you can then
leverage that replicated capability
feature from conference on top of that
and replicate the data pretty easily
from on-prem to GCD now all your
existing systems are already pushing
their to cover so you hardly have to do
anything and then the data once it comes
to GCP then the same get a pipeline
which it alter when earlier it can be
triggered on and then the data can go
into all this different parts from
visualization to function so Venus to D
and so on and so forth I'm going to hand
it over to Josh now who is our cast iron
content expert to walk you through what
exactly spawn strength plow and
replicated in case equal all these cool
technologies that you see in this room
Josh what do you cool yeah I think so I
think I did a pretty good job of
describing compo cloud and it's tight
immigration to GCP the idea here is
really that for existing kafka users
we're trying to simplify and ease their
adoption journey to the cloud and so I
started to mention there's a bunch of
different ways you can do this there's a
number of like he could go on
point-to-point from a database directly
to bigquery but we think that for coffee
users since Kafka is oftentimes kind of
the way that those systems connect that
tapping into that existing koepcke
infrastructure getting that creating
that persistent bridge that real-time
bridge to the cloud and then being able
to integrate directly to GCD for
starting services start building
applications with the data from on-prem
in the cloud is really compelling and so
confluent cloud a sarthak mentioned it's
a fully managed service and so this this
makes the the journey a bit easier right
so you're not having to manage Kafka on
Prem and then manage Kafka in the cloud
we take that burden away from you I
wanted to talk a little bit about the
two components on that last slide
confluent cloud and replicator so a
confluent replicator on that slide it
looked like it was actually got part of
both of sides of that right so it was
part on pram and
part in the cloud it's actually a you
know part of the connect framework or
uses the connect framework and is a
connector it's a complicated connector
that has a bunch of cool stuff that
makes it super resilient but it's a
connector that either runs on the origin
cluster or at the destination so it's
sort of pulling data across a network or
it's pushing data across a network in
typically we have it pull data but you
can run it in either pattern and so this
conflict replicator allows allows us a
really nice clean story to tap into
existing copy infrastructure without
really having to touch anything right so
we don't have to go touch those
databases
we're only I'm hooking into the existing
Kafka installation on Prem a confluent
cloud as sarthak mentioned it's a it's a
fully managed service if you're if
you've ever managed copy before you know
it can be challenging right so it's a
distributed system of Kafka brokers it's
a distributed system of zookeepers Kafka
Connect is a distributed system and so
there's a lot of complexity here that
that we hide from you so you don't know
how many brokers there are you don't
know about zookeeper when you run in the
connect framework you you know this is
from a UI where you just point and click
so we really we think that this is a
whole new way to run Kafka kind of a
cloud native Kafka that's the super
compelling and it's not just Kafka that
we're running we're running schema
registry
we're running a sequel to mention we're
running connectors for you so if you
want to connect to bigquery you don't
have to you know figure out how much
data you're moving there you just go to
the UI so you want to connect this topic
to bigquery and it starts moving and
then we allow you to store as much data
you want us on that Kafka cluster as you
need right so you can store an infinite
amount of data in those topics so adding
these two features you know if we take a
step down right from the the more market
sector slide if we if we think about
existing customers that have on-premise
copy infrastructure whether it's open
source Apache Kafka confluent Enterprise
right so they can they can use complan
replicator they can run it on Prem they
can run it in GC P and now they can
create this real-time stream of data to
complement cloud once the data's in
conflict a CAD Vantage of those fully
managed connectors and just start
pumping data into the services that
their mo
interested in the COS also have
applications that start directly
integrating with with comfortable cloud
right so building micro-services and an
event-driven way and using Kafka as the
mechanism to do that this super common
pattern so now you can have confluent
cloud there as your event ribbon
microservices coffee let's talk about a
couple use cases here to start right
just wanted to talk about like the fact
that this is a super a kind of simple
horizontal use case that can be used
practically for anything as sarthak
mentioned earlier any use case where you
need real-time data that doesn't live on
GCP this is pretty well suited for we're
taking advantage of the fact that
something like you know it's something
like 70 75 % of Fortune 500 companies
already run Kafka so the Assumption here
is that that can be a vast source of
data that we can easily tap into and
start creating this real-time data
pipeline once we have this flow of
real-time data we can start building
solutions with it right so if the flow
is from a mainframe and you have
financial data now you can start
building some fraud analytics on that if
you're a telecom you know you probably
want to think about do I have anomalous
activity at my antennas right like that
might be something you're looking at but
effectively the pattern we're talking
about is the building the data
infrastructure to get data to GCP and
then you customer can build the business
solution that you want to build one
really cool pattern that we see a lot is
using this for multi cloud so the you
know a lot of customers have already you
know they live in one cloud but they
they started to think like we need to
find the best of breed technologies
across the clouds and use that and in
the data analytics world that's GCP so a
lot of customers want to move to GCP for
bigquery but the data they want to use
in bigquery might not live there so if
the data if that's a Kafka user we can
use that exact same pattern right hook
up replicator confluent cloud and GCP
and just start feeding bigquery so your
system of record may live in a different
cloud but you can actually use that data
and pretty much near real-time in GCP in
bigquery we actually have custom
they're kind of doing this right so you
need technologies who GCP and confluent
a joint webinar with moved from another
cloud to GCP by building this bridge and
they moved to GCP because they wanted
data flow and bigquery and they were a
Kafka customer so this is the pattern
they used so sir thick maybe you can
just walk us through like how customers
might use this for AI n mm yeah no Thank
You Josh
so this particular architecture diagram
which you are seeing this is actual
customer implementation for a customer
in the banking space who wanted to
handle a better fraud detection more
near real depth fraud detection using G
Series capabilities but they had
tremendous data gravity on Prem because
they are got a lot of data in mainframes
in in Hadoop in Oracle here at a net set
relying on Prem Plus they had a whole
bunch of data from different from
different stores to like mobile devices
to web which is constantly coming in and
all the systems are set up to receive
the data
thankfully they are already using Kafka
to communicate across all these
disparate systems as a message broker on
trim and and what we did was we deployed
constant cloud and BS function
replicator like what we have been
talking about to move some of the data
to DCP now as a first step what they are
doing is they are actually taking of
fully data which is something every day
rather in near real-time as the more
data is coming in they're actually
flowing is reading a flow for doing some
processing storing the full data source
our data are then a stream in bigquery
because in bigquery now you can do a lot
faster analysis across those terabytes
or petabytes of data then what you could
have done on Prem especially across all
those discrete systems and then they are
doing a visualizations of the data using
local but probably more interesting is
they are actually doing in a constant
cloud they are actually sorting out some
specific data streams and those data
streams they are they are training some
fraud models and they are actually
passing it to those fraud they are
deploying those fraud models and
they are sending those data are to run
those fraud models to determine what are
those transactions have any fraudulent
behavior in them and then finally they
are using actually sending the data to
our to account for topic on running
unconstrained cloud so that they can
then send it back that feedback
downstream to their to their own Prem
system so that based on on the
transaction being determined to be
fraudulent or not they can actually take
actions on the systems it is not it is a
second and you guys will will appreciate
and understand and relate that this is
though this particular case is part of
fraud detection application but a very
similar pattern can be applied to almost
every other use case from consumer
behavior analysis to market analysis
every other business scenario which you
can think of if it if it satisfy the
criterias of like hailing you have you
are already invested in Kafka on Prem
and you want to start leveraging the GCP
services like AI ml or visualizations or
bigquery those things immediately
without having to move all that it are
neither have to wait for you to move all
the later to cloud so this kind of sums
up the core messaging with how can a
hybrid data pipeline can solve those
business problems so thank you very much
for attending a session I want to hand
it over to Josh who have a call to
action for all of you so Josh please
take it away
Thanks yeah I think you know what I
would love is if your if this sounds
interesting to you please check out
confluent cloud it's you can spin up a
cop the cluster in about 10 seconds and
confluent covers the first $200 for the
first three months for everybody so it's
effectively free to try check it out
play around some k sequel and hopefully
you love it
thanks for joining